we have a new sponsor for today's show
now this doesn't happen often
but i have never in my life heard of a
company or product
like the one you're about to see it's
perfectly designed to help you feel
better
during troubling times and these are
troubling times i truly think it might
become
the next big thing check it out
has this ever happened to you have
simple chores
stopped feeling simple and you're
starting to feel like you just can't do
anything right plus there's all that pet
hair
and this unruly garden hose but have you
ever tried
doing it in color because doing it in
color makes
everything easier yes
nice did you have a terrible 2020
just because you didn't do it in color
oh no it's because
then learn from your mistakes and do
this year right
by doing it in color call our not fake
number now
to receive our patented step-by-step
guide that combines elements of science
and the occult to allow you to do
everything in color when just remember
to call us in color
or you'll never get through good luck
do it in color yeah